hi everyone I'm Lia Cilan the executive
director of nem focus and this is Gina
halfrek our communication director and
also our program manager for diversity
and inclusion
so very important very important to jobs
there and James is also on here I don't
know he may be coming in he may not so
we wanted to have James as our volunteer
extraordinaire and let him talk to you a
little bit about that but if he can make
it great and if not we'll we'll go on so
our goal here is to mainly give you a
little bit more information about nem
focus and hopefully you can take that
with you and if you come across someone
who doesn't know who none focuses or
what not focuses and what we do you'll
be able to help us in getting our
getting our message out all right so
let's see if this is all right so now
focus is working that we all have better
tools to build a better world so we are
working on behalf of the projects and
tools that that you're using so these
are these are the projects we have 23
projects right now there's one that
actually we have not received their logo
yet a brand new project called Cantera
and we are the projects the projects are
very we've got you know there's
visualization there is machine learning
if there are some educational programs
are software and data carpentry open
journals we have project economists we
have pandas we've got julia and stan and
are open sai and python so that's four
languages that are represented under our
umbrella we're very excited about that
and we try to constantly make sure that
we're representing all of all of the
projects and focus was the founding
board members were all authors of Python
based tools
but from the very beginning to make sure
that all right so net focus is making an
impact in several different ways all
right is that better
okay sorry we are powering scientific
discovery so a lot of our tools are
being used for some major research
initiatives as well as scientific
discoveries we have a scope I and some
PI just doing incredible things with
astronomy we have several tools that are
being used for medical research and just
working bioinformatics a lot of tools
being used on in for biology research
supporting technical innovation so we
have the the list kind of goes on there
we could go on and on about the
technology side but it mentions here on
the slide Facebook Microsoft Azure
machine learning studio Intel
distribution for Python Apple OS both OS
X and also also Stan is being used in
Facebook so just kind of all across the
board we could go on and on Nielsen and
Netflix we could just keep going there
and fighting human trafficking a lot of
the tools have been used in several
initiatives that are being used to fight
human trafficking so why not focus none
focus is here to meet the critical needs
of these projects there before nem focus
was founded there was not an
organization that was working to support
scientific computing tools and just
doing just supporting scientific
computing tools and that is why it was
originally founded the founders felt
like you know they there needed to
a place if these projects were to
receive funding this was back in 2012
where would that money land and who
would provide that support
so besides funding stability
independence and logistical support so
we're going to kind of go by these go
talk about a few topics that based on
each one of these so fiscal and legal
services so this is part of our fiscal
sponsorship programs so I mentioned if
projects get funding if they should
receive a grant where does that money go
so a project cannot receive grant money
whether it's support corporate support
or support from a foundation it's very
difficult unless they are a 501c3 or
unless they're their own legal entity so
most projects are not so we provide that
home and then we also manage that
funding so that funding comes in who's
going to create invoices who's going to
write checks he's going to keep track of
the checks he's going to make sure that
the disbursements are being spent as
those who are donating the money wished
them to be who's going to guarantee that
he's going to accept liability for the
project so none focus does that legal
services lots of legal services you
would be surprised on how many times our
projects reach out for help
legally whether it's to register a
trademark whether there's a licensing
question just contracts independent
contract agreements different kinds of
we do a whole lot of contract agreements
so there is just several times probably
several times a week that we get phone
calls our emails from projects asking
for help and we have to reach out to the
attorney so each of our fiscal fiscally
sponsored projects receive ten hours of
ten hours of legal support all right
financial services that's the other so
as I mentioned accounts payable in
seeing contractor agreements we also
take care of 999 90 is the filing taxes
for the project so that's what
nonprofits file 990 and we take care of
that so none of our projects have to
worry about they have funding coming in
you don't have to worry about you know
taxes for those so it's important that
we can take care of all of the admin and
the projects can take care of writing
the code operational services technical
infrastructure we're I think I mentioned
earlier that we're working on a shared
infrastructure project and that way our
projects can share resources because
there's a lot of needs that they have
that none focus can provide and that
they can all take part in kind of share
across the board Gina will mention a
little bit more about that when she
talks about some some future initiatives
conference and event planning so pie
data is one of those events also are
project specific events there's Julia
Kahn and there Stan Khan and there's
Phoenix con and you you know there's
yeah we could Jupiter con you know we
could just go on and on with all the
other cons that we have but events are
extremely important and so to be able to
provide support for those events on the
logistical side and then consulting lots
of different administration
administrative requests come in
sustainability pretty much everything we
do is for project sustainability there
whether it's the fiscal sponsorship
program whether it is making sure their
events are supported we have a
sustainability program and a projects
director that is in charge Christy
that's in charge of our sustainability
program we just had a summit where there
was a workshop focused on sustainability
where projects were able to come
together and discuss specific needs and
come up with action plans on how those
needs could be met so it's something
that is on our minds all the time how
are we going to keep these projects
around what are their specific
needs and how can them focus help to
meet those community why is public
engagement important for projects that
is that's a question that is you know a
lot of people ask but it's it's pretty
easily answered it's needed first of all
a project needs users and secondly we
need to make sure that the public is not
only educated on what's happening with
the project's new releases new features
how to use those and that's another
another issue that the events you know
can definitely that's what you're here
for right now learning all the sessions
but also to make sure there is a
renewable contributor base so we want to
make sure there's new people
contributing to these projects new
maintainer 'he's coming on board we
don't want there to be you know we don't
want project leads to be burnt out and
then no one be there in their place
there's a lot of work that has to be
done from documentation to project
management to community management and
we want to make sure that the community
is involved and understands the need for
not only being involved on the community
level by attending events and using the
project but also working to maintain the
projects educational programs that is
one way that we meet the community needs
pie data is one of those google Summer
of Code is another one meetups videos
workshops lots of different ways that we
help work on help with the community
support on the educational level so pie
dado want to talk a little bit about pie
data this impact and you are all here
sir all part of pie data we have I don't
know the exact number that this event is
but I think we are on 20 I want to say
28 maybe 28 pie data's that we've that
we've done so far
started in 2012 and the
actually the first one full kind of
conference was here in New York in 2012
so alright so 11 conferences 330
speakers 3500 plus attendees and 165
diversities scholarships that's for this
that's for this year Wow
these this is also the gross proceeds
are benefiting them focused now this
expenses aren't it's gross aren't taken
out of this but PI data events are is a
fundraising vehicle for an unfocused we
don't try to you know hide that we're
very upfront that these events help us
do you support the projects and go
directly to project grants whatever's
left so after we cover all the cost of
Pi data events then that money is put
right back into the project goes goes
nowhere else this is really important
for being able to bring projects
together for summits and things like
that
that funding comes so when you attend a
PI data event we hope it's going to be
beneficial to you on a hopefully you're
going to be able to share your knowledge
and be able to gain some knowledge but
you're also providing direct support to
the project so we appreciate that and
when Microsoft Bloomberg when we have
IBM when they host events that is a huge
huge huge help to it none focus and the
work we're trying to do this is
something we're excited about our
meetups have doubled this year so the
number of the members of these are just
PI data meetups so a lot of our projects
have made ups also membership has grown
to 50,000 plus we have and you can see
where they're located we're not quite
sure what's going on with Australia but
we're working on it
YouTube videos we have 1100 YouTube
videos and 35 thousand subscriber
subscribers 1.7 million views so we feel
like the pipe
data conferences do a lot supporting the
community on the educational level but
the videos reach those who are never
able to come to PI data as we have some
people we meet that have attended some
of our European conferences that are
able to make it and say they were
completely learned from the ground up
from watching PI data videos so we're
very excited about that and are very
grateful to our speakers who give their
time I think that's all the high points
there this is what makes up non focus we
have our staff of six we have our board
of directors
we have an advisory council a
sustainability Advisory Council in a
diversity and inclusion committee so
please visit our website and you can see
who's on these specifics we won't kind
of go through it one by one but I will
let Gina talk to you a little bit about
kind of looking ahead and some things
that 2018 is going to bring and then
we'll take questions thanks Leah um so
number focus has been growing at quite a
clip as both an organization and a
broader community so as Leah was
mentioning we have doubled the number of
members in our global PI data meetups we
continuously have more and more local
communities who reach out to us and say
we're really excited to do a conference
can we bring up high data conferenced
here this year we had our first
conference in India we had our first
conference in South America in san luis
argentina we had our first conference in
PI data Warsaw the folks in Japan have
been talking to us so it just keeps
growing and growing which is really
exciting we are continuously growing as
an organization as Leah mentioned we
just got our 23rd open source project
I imagine that we will add more over
2018 as we continue to get applications
and approve them to join the
organization we have grown from Leah
running them focus as a one-woman show
from 2012 to 2015 to now having six
staff members to support all these
projects and the skirling community so
it's really exciting some of the
technical shared infrastructure that
we've been talking about things like
shared server space ci website you know
you name it so many common needs of
open-source projects the more that we
can kind of pull them together to
benefit one another the better we have a
wonderful track record of growing our
dumb focus membership as a nonprofit
members in the organization can do
things like vote on certain things
having to do with you know governance
and board etc so we've been growing very
much this year today is giving Tuesday
we did a friend raiser it's still going
on you can participate and we're really
it focused on continuing to grow our
membership number Coast is only five
we're almost at the end of 2017 five
years old and so as compared to
something like Python Software
Foundation we're still quite small but
I'm very excited to help the
organization to continue to grow in that
respect we're also looking forward to
bringing on more corporate partners to
work with us as you have seen every
major technology company relies on them
focused tools and so we want them to be
working with us in partnership to make
sure that those tools have a long
sustainable future ahead of them
so basically growth growth growth this
is the theme for 2018 I think we will
probably will hit some of the growing
pains so going through that but we're
really excited about it continuing to
offer more resources more opportunities
to get connected to the community I
think relying on digital communities is
going to be a big part of that given
that we are global and international and
allowing folks who are really passionate
and excited about the mission to get
involved as they see fit so we'd love to
take your questions
Kelly sure so our our board right now we
have a board of of six we had one person
that just moved from our board so when
when someone's a board member they have
once they decide you know it's time for
them to leave the board they are asked
every two years if they would like to
stay on the board or if they would like
to leave the board at that time and many
of them have gone to our Advisory
Council so our advisory councils made up
of a few past board members as well as
those that are corporate partners at our
over there
sorry at our top two levels they also
receive a seat on the Advisory Council
so the board the board right now is self
electing that we do take nominations
from the pub from you know just public
nominations and we usually will have a
board election coming up pretty soon and
then they will you know will put in just
kind of put a notice out tweet it send
the email out put it on the newsletter
and then when those nominations come in
then they go through a process so that's
that's how the board is working right
now the board is responsible for making
major strategic decisions for the
organization the as in any nonprofit the
board of directors is also you know
legally responsible for you know making
decisions and the board both in my
cellphone liability wise but that's
that's kind of does that answer your
question Kelly is that
so we are so the board and one thing I
forgot to mention and then I'll answer
that question is that we do have bylaws
and so the board is working under a set
of bylaws we're in the process right now
of going through those bylaws there's
been several amendments made but you
make your bylaws when you first write
your 501c3 documentation and then you go
back and you're like oh wait that's you
know that's that's not exactly what
we're you know we've kind of decided
that this is a better option and so then
you have to you know pass the board
resolves to pass those amendments so
that's kind of that's kind of where
where we are where we are now on that
and then what was the other strategic
planning so right now we don't have like
you can't go to our website and look for
an unfocused a strategic strategic plan
we are in the process right now because
of what Gina mentioned the tremendous
growth of the organization in trying to
plan a road map and figure out where
we're going so there's been I think the
last two board meetings have talked
about this and so we are hoping to be
able to have something out we're redoing
our website which should be coming out
the first of the year and then we'll
also be putting out our annual report
and hopefully within all of that will be
also working on a strategic strategic
plan so the creative ideas to to do what
Odin I'm focused so none focus was the
the idea of the first five original I
guess founding board members where
Travis Oliphant and Fernando Perez and
John tender so we have Fernando from
ipython at that was pre Jupiter days
Travis from nem PI as well as sy pi John
Hunter from matplotlib Perry greenfield
from aster PI and
Jared Millman was working at Berkeley
with Fernando and then Anthony scope ATS
came on as our first treasure the to
answer your second question
no definitely we could find we could we
could find a really good use for that I
definitely would not screw us up
whatsoever but I do think that you know
it is important to make sure that you
know you're not only raising money but
that you do have you know you do have
some sort of direction and path that you
want to see that funding used for you
know where is it going to be channeled
and what's the best use of those funds
that are that are coming in
the short answer is yes one of for
example one of the ideas that is still
in sort of the a-courtin stage and
hopefully will soon be a huge oak tree
that came out of the focus some it was
about convening some of the major
players in the space to talk about their
approach to supporting open source tools
so I fully expect that to happen and
bear quite a lot of fruit there's also a
broad coalition of people who are really
invested in helping to communicate both
to the broader community of users and to
corporations the vulnerability of open
source tools which if even the most
cursory search will you don't raise for
you a variety of concerns on that level
that heartbleed was a really big
security issue which was partly
traceable to relying on open source
project that was just one person kind of
holding it together right and so numb
focus exists to help prevent situations
like that for example there's a report
called the roads and bridges report
which is comparing open-source software
to physical infrastructure written by an
idea echo who is on our sustainability
advisory board that is a great example
of some ground work that's being done to
help communicate this out and sonam
focuses very much
you know considers itself an active
player in connecting the dots for the
folks who hold hold the paycheck the
checkbooks at major corporations and
making sure that support for the open
source tools that they use and which
power all of their great products is
support yes yes so our advisory board as
we mentioned is full of folks who think
about this stuff very much there are a
lot of very active conversations
happening right now about the the right
approach and the variety of options for
what that might look like
yeah just one other comment
that I think that as more industry
partners kind of I guess kind of start
the trend of others you know they're
these corporate partners down here that
are you know they're leading and eggs
yeah
oh no there should be and and these are
our PI data sponsors down there one two
three four five six are our corporate
partners and those corporate partners
are donating you know tune um focus we
have like I said a few more coming on
that are a few of them specifically you
know have designated funds for a
particular project but I think that what
we're hearing believe it or not is that
a lot of a lot of folks in industry are
not aware that there is a need here they
are we're very surprised I don't know if
you were you know I saw on Twitter some
of the tweets regarding pandas
supporting pandas but right after that
you know I think we received three
corporate partners just from that
conversation and all of them were like
we had no idea we had no idea that your
projects needed funding so I it's hard
for us we're working on it we've got it
yes we're working on and it seems like I
know it seems like we're saying we're
working we're working on it but we are
working on it as fast as we can and it
is it's I mean just integral to our
efforts to be able to communicate this
clearly and to have others to be able to
take it to those in their company or be
able to access this information so we
want to make sure we have something in
print we have an e-book we have these
tools to where people can take them and
say look this is what you need to do
here's a solution we're using these
tools they're very important to our work
we need to give back and make sure that
those tools are sustainable so
right right if you're going to be using
these tools yeah we have to we have to
change the mindset of you know you know
not I you know we keep saying industry
but I think it's across the board
everyone needs to understand you're
using these tools we need to you know we
need to help ya
the criteria are on the website and it
would be I will probably fill this pop
quiz but you know scientific computing
data science focused has to have a
fairly broad contributor base the
maintainer can't all work for one
company you know it has to be just
spread out
I forget the others it's only being used
by you know a very small you know a
small portion of the public that you
know it has to be far-reaching enough
that it's fulfilling our mission to you
know meet meet public needs yes
um how do we carve out the strategic
plan as I'm sure there there is not
really we we get a lot we are projects
as well as I'm focus as a whole receive
funding from both Sloan and Moore
Foundation and they're both have told us
that we're kind of you know we're one of
a kind there are other organizations
that provide fiscal sponsorship but they
don't provide other sustainability
support so they don't you know some do
events some don't but they the ones that
are 501 C 3 s that are also fiscal
sponsors don't to the same extent do
what we're doing so there isn't a
specific model but we can look to other
organizations and we've done that in the
past and see you know see what they're
doing
you know Apache foundation has has a
model it's very different from ours but
they do have you know success with their
model and so it's important to be able
to be aware of other things that are out
there you know what's Apache doing
what's what is the Linux Foundation
doing and you know be able to pull from
those idea you know from ideas that are
proving themselves successful for them
but also making sure we're keeping with
the same licensing and ideas that none
focus was founded on and making sure
we're carrying out that mission a lot of
it has to do with licensing and what is
required of the projects there's some IP
differences I won't go into all of them
because I'm not I don't have it all in
front of me and I've definitely not
knowledgeable enough to be able to you
I'm afraid of will say something
incorrect and I don't want to do that or
lead you in the wrong liji on the wrong
path but there's a lot of the
differences are license all of our
projects are OSI approved license
and so we want to make sure that you
know that we that we stay with that and
that the projects them focus does not
own the copyright or does not own the
copyright to the IP right in scientific
computing we are yeah as Gina said we're
definitely our focus if you will is on
scientific computing data science
scientific computing realm and so if a
project applies and they may be a great
project it might be widely used it might
be something very important for the
public but it's it's outside of kind of
our scope then it's not a great fit for
our organization we want to make sure
that that our focus is you know right on
the community that we serve so a large a
large part of that will go to go to
staff support we all have unfortunately
have to be or fortunately whoever you're
looking at it have to be paid so that is
that's part of it we also you know there
of any organization you know we have
rent we have everything so whether we're
having corporate funds whether it's
coming from individual donations whether
it's coming from a grant whether you
know whatever it is we have to you know
we have operational overhead that has to
be paid so some of that goes towards
that anything that is left is given to
our projects in small project grants so
we'll have we'll open up we'll say okay
we have so much money
projects you let us know what you need
both are sponsored projects as well as
our affiliated projects and so we'll
just you know the board will decide
usually I think last time we ended up
giving 13 grants out some
[Music]
sure
sure sure did everyone hear the question
so she's asking how much of our I guess
our total budget is how much of that
goes to our admin and operational cost
and how much of that goes straight to
projects or in the nonprofit world you
say how much goes to your program and
how much is you know your admin
operational cost so across the board for
nonprofits a healthy number you want to
stay under 30 under 30 percent so we
have gone anywhere from 15 to about 25
so I think right now we are right at
about and we'll we'll do another check
at the end of the year we check to
constantly make sure we're kind of where
we need to be I read it about 25 20 to
25 and uh-huh mm-hmm
where everything else going to going to
program right and that's that's for six
we'd like to be able to have more
funding come in so we can you know we'd
like to be able to get that number down
but as our project needs increase so
does the need for first staff so yeah
yeah
[Music]
it doesn't scale well thank you yeah I
think for an organization with a mission
like num focus it's also a little bit
different than looking at something like
an American Heart Association or
something because for example the salary
that we pay to our projects finance
manager goes to essentially pay for
critical services as she's providing two
of the projects so even though you know
that money isn't sort of being turned
over to developers it is saving them
time that they otherwise would be doing
you know invoices and things like that
so I think we're almost at wrap up but
we have another question yes Jim why is
our Events Coordinator for none focus
works on all these conferences and also
our project conferences so definitely
chat with him if you're interested in
volunteering in a great job with this
[Applause]
yeah that's great feedback um also to
Jim's credit he's only been on board for
a handful of weeks so where we're
working towards seamless collaboration
on things like that going forward yeah
yes thank you for coming you can read
more about us on the website come back
in a month for a much improved website I
encourage you to follow us on Twitter
like us on Facebook subscribe to our
newsletter become a member
thank you
[Applause]